Jake Paul had a fight this weekend did
you lots of fight I definitely ordered
it yeah same 100 as well great fight
yeah it really was fantastic fight oh it
was a good fight but you know what's so
interesting you watch it yeah I saw
Clips but it looked like a lot of sloppy
boxes no it was a great and it was like
I mean Tommy Fury is not a great boxer
either yeah both of them showed
excellent boxing IQ and then started to
make changes in real time so much no but
Jake did because the thing is that Tommy
had a [__] chin on him so so what
happened is Tommy starts peppering Jake
with his jab Tommy's got like these
really long arms like if you look at uh
Tyson as well he's got these like
freakishly long arms so Tommy was doing
this thing and this is the most
difficult thing for Jake Jake has like
the nuclear bomb is this big overhand
right so what he does is feel
predictable in this fight though oh my
God here's the thing in order to land
that big overhand right he needs
somebody to throw a jab and he said time
the jab slip it and then come over so as
but but Tommy kept hitting them with
them
and the arms are long enough that even
when Jake did land it was coming right
before him or it hit his shoulder or
whatever so all of a sudden I saw that
immediately I go okay this is this is
this is going to be tricky Jake makes an
adjustment Jake starts slipping that jab
and then throwing these big left Hooks
and lands but Tommy had a [__] phone
no he called him a couple times Tommy
definitely got a chin but I also think
that Tommy moving naturally as a boxer
[__] Jacob yes because Jake and I used
to being in the ring with people who
actually move in the distance that he
kept so like that boxing distance
maintaining that distance staying right
outside of the range knowing when it
come in when you're a kickboxer like
when you're going up against guys who
traditionally trained in Muay Thai or
kickboxing there isn't movement you
stand kind of right in front of one
another and then you kick they kick it's
like sock and Bop him in a lot like and
it's not to say they aren't skilled but
it's just a different style of
Engagement so when Jake is going up
against a guy like that who's going to
stand in front of him he could lose
[__] big right hand up when you're
fighting NBA players and former MMA
fighters you don't know how to move like
a boxer they clearly beat Anderson Silva
now here's the thing this is not a boxer
but he has he's had eight fights or
something between science man point is
this is the I think this is the best
thing to happen to Jake why I don't I'll
explain why
his stock was too high for the money
fights the money fights for Jake in my
opinion are not fighting real boxers
the money fights for Jake are fighting
celebrities I agree so he when he beat
Anderson Silva and convincingly and
dropped him after that I go I don't
think I don't think uh KSI can beat him
and KSI is the big money fight him
losing to Tommy who's a boxer but he's
not a [__] top ranked boxer by any
means I don't know so him losing but to
Tommy makes all the other celebrities
that also box go oh I might be able to
beat that [__] stay in your lane
Jake fight the celebrities already
celebrities or the MMA guys so I look at
this and I go okay if he beats Tommy if
I'm KSI I'm going I'm not fighting this
[__] this guy's a legit amazing
[__] box he just be the guy who's
dedicated his life to boxing okay no
Tommy's boxes whole life yeah but I grew
up in a boxer now he was a reality star
you can see a reality stars like flaccid
or some [__] like that
I don't know
hilarious
you take him you take a guy like like a
jake and now you go even when Jake beat
Anderson Silva and convincingly
I was like I don't think Nate Diaz can
be Jake I think Jake has these MMA
fighters numbers I don't think that
that's actually a good fight now that he
lost to Tommy I start going oh this nape
fight is interesting this KSI fight is
interesting and those are the lucrative
fights you're saying if he beat uh to
Fury he would have gone from a celebrity
who boxes to a boxer in our eyes because
he finally beat a real boxer real money
off it's like I'm not fine and then he
could only fight real by boxers and then
he'd have harder fights for less money
so he'd have to fight he'd have to fight
because I think he'd still be to draw
he's still generate Mad Money raw for
Jake is to watch him lose it's very
similar to Mayweather he's positioned
himself as a heel yeah right and it's
incredibly difficult thing to do
emotionally like you're just dealing
with hate non-fucking stop like the his
like resilience emotionally to handling
this like I love the way you lost bro he
owned that [__] he said now don't get me
wrong he did throw out a couple of
ailments you know what I mean he was
like I got a hurt arm and I was
something else like he named like three
things but I'm like for the most part he
was like don't judge me how um
I like the way he handed it career-wise
making money-wise this is the best thing
I don't need to see a rematch with Tommy
like I don't care about it no I know he
might care about for ego but I don't
care about now what I want to see him do
is fight KSI or Nate Diaz you beat KSI
then you fight Nate Diaz you beat Nate
Diaz you rematch Tommy and ideally Tommy
has kind of like increased is profiled
by having other legitimate boxing fights
as well you have one more big one here
and it's not like he's got his ass
kicked I mean
that's why I feel like there's not any
basic boxer can beat Jake Paul
well that's
so that's what especially in the
Cruiserweight division that's what
they're gonna claim right that's what I
think I believe that and it's reasonable
thinking but that's what they're going
to claim they're gonna play okay he
finally fought a boxer and someone who
is skilled in boxing specifically not
MMA but boxing is going to be able to
beat every time and that's and that's
what they'll probably say right but in
my mind it's like you're in this for
money right you're not in this to prove
that you're a [__] box if his goal is
to be a great boxer which he said that's
his goal then it impacts his overall I
think the more you win the more you
think is possible as you should so as
he's beating all these MMA guys he's
like yeah I think you gotta take a boxer
maybe this is God's way being like save
your brain and just go fight KSI yeah go
fight celebrities yeah you're not I'm
not you're too late in this boxing thing
yeah what I hated is like all the uh and
I it finally dawned on me why they were
riding for him so hard like Sean Porter
was really riding for Jake Paul yeah but
it's because they're both from Ohio you
know what I mean but they kept saying
things like he's finally out of Tyson
Fury Shadow no you're not Tommy Tyson
Fury is the heavyweight champion of the
the [__] world yeah yeah this man has
been in the ring fighting Wars yeah okay
you beat Jake Paul
still in your brother's shadow
yeah yeah like you have to be like like
you'd have to do triple with uh Tyson
Fury has done in his boxing career you
gotta get out of that shadow it's not
bad to be in the shadow of arguably the
greatest heavyweight ever come on yeah
knocked out by the hardest puncher in
the world multiple times in one down yes
but yeah yes and got up yeah and then
the next two fights wasn't even close
yeah third fight was was more decent
than the second fight but come on like
stuff are they full Brothers I think
nothing like that yeah I think the Dare
got another got you I think Tommy was in
good shape assuming but yeah it makes
sense Tommy was in good shape yo yeah
like I'm like as soon as I'm like oh his
Tommy's gonna be Jake Paul yeah that
first round I didn't think it was gonna
be a knockout but I just like yo he's
gonna beat Jake I don't know if this
applies but I remember one thing Andrew
said about Anthony Anthony Joshua all
those big muscles get you worn out
quicker because they take a lot need a
lot of oxygen and Tommy has some big
[__] money Joshua was never
that good I told you this a million
times nice guy great guy I've never
believed in Anthony Joshua is a fighter
ever I believe that at the time and uh I
feel like every even before he got to U6
you know and uh uh what's the other dude
who beat him can't even remember his
name now Anthony Ruiz oh yeah Andy Ruiz
Andrew Ruiz before that I thought
Deontay would have beat Anthony Joshua I
thought Ortiz would have beat Anthony
Joshua Tyson Fury come on guys come on
come on you wouldn't even want that yeah
why did they have a smaller ring what
was the purpose of that I don't know who
wanted that something Mommy wanted it
Tommy wanted it yeah that's really
interesting because I think that
actually benefits Jake because Jake's
not a dancer Jake is coming straight
forward he's coming at you he wants to
engage so Tommy is more of like a boxer
so you would think that he would want
more room so he could dance but if he
wanted the smaller ring it means he
wants to get in there and bang right you
know what I hated about the fight was
the [__] referee trying to be the MVP
I hate him oh my God that's the
attention you know you're fighting
experience why are you let them go a
little bit I thought that neither one of
them did anything that was flagrant like
I guess maybe there was some leaning yes
there was some holding but no more than
you would see in everything just break
them up and take away the point yeah
that was stupid and they did it for both
of them so I guess it evened out but
like I hate a referee that like makes it
about them I think that was a makeup
deduction I think
and then he was like but are you
deducting anything from them let them
bang out like who gives a [__] I thought
the fight was great I thought it was
real it was entertaining great fight you
gotta watch it yeah I gotta say this
I've not been disappointed by Jake Paul
because they both made adjustments like
Jake was getting caught with a jab and
all of a sudden Jake started to stick
this long jab and then he started
catching um well Tommy right and then
Tommy made this adjustment where he
noticed that Jake was really like
ducking when he would throw the jab so
Tommy would throw this uppercut as Jake
were duck and it was like I'm seeing I
was seeing like really high IQ box it's
hard to go in there and worry about
getting your [__] head caved in yeah
while also going okay he's doing this
thing I'm gonna change my game plan and
do that thing on the Fly and they both
did it Jay got a lot of Mexican in them
bro
because I watched the last fight last
fight he got windy who was the last by
silver right yeah you could tell he got
tired but he gets better but he was as
the fight goes on like it's almost like
he gets stronger and he'd be looking
like red hair all over the place but he
just don't stop working bro he's a dog
Jake's a dog he's a Mexican
not a lot of Mexican Fighting him yo he
do he got elect a lot of Mexicans fight
in him yo honey will knock him the [__]
out though huh Canelo will knock him the
[__] up yeah I don't think he wants
something no no leave that alone leave
that alone yeah yeah but we don't want
to see like I want to see the KSI fight
that has so much buildup I think they
fought already no no no KSI fought Logan
twice oh okay so this is the get back
and I think the KSI watches that and now
maybe it brings Jake back to reality a
little bit whereas before after that
silver fight if I'm can't say I'm going
I focus I do 10 other [__] projects
this is a part-time gig for me and this
guy's dedicated full time to [__]
boxing
I can't compete with that but maybe now
I think Tyson Fury should fight Logan
bro oh dude come on bro no no I do in in
WWE no no I think they should just bucks
Logan was talking spicy yo I think that
was kind of wild that's what I'm saying
Logan was talking about the family yo I
think what do you say about the family
yeah I think he said Tom if you can hear
me you're a [__] your whole family is
[__] that's right
that was wild give Logan a title shot
by the way I just told you how to play
the Creed Three
give the guy who's only had one fight no
fight back no no one fight a title shot
no no fights yeah get a guy a title shot
why did he get the title shot
I mean I don't want to give it all that
away but yeah when you look at it it
kind of makes sense like it could happen
but he's also maybe a little corny like
if you're a fan of boxing you're like yo
that would never happen that wouldn't
happen but maybe it could if you are the
promoter God you know what I'm saying so
type of Fury could say I want to fight
Logan Paul it's a big money I saw this
is a plot of creed too to be fair this
guy in Russia this promoter is like
let's make that fight happen that's
Drago sign yeah
it's a crazy money
did Logan might die yeah like literally
no I think Tyson he wouldn't he'll go
halfway he wouldn't try to kill him but
he could kill him he could kill him if
he wanted to kill him no that's a choice
I don't want to be in the ring with
someone that's going halfway just so I
don't die
like rushing once Logan might have said
it no one this guy's not gonna kill me
I'm too small it's too easy I don't
think Johnson would kill him Tyson would
know Tyson would [__] him up but he
would know not to like I'm not gonna
kill you he might just knock him out
with body shots or some [__] like that
like Tyson has that IQ but I don't want
to watch that fight either really I
don't want to watch someone take it easy
right damn we're watching it for Carnage
right no I don't want to see Logan die I
like Logan not die yeah but I don't want
to see I don't see anybody die but I
want to see two fighters going at it uh
Jake Fighters they were both going out
even Logan employed it was cool because
oh yeah one has a crazy height advantage
and everything boy was trying to get
Logan out of here we're trying to get
Logan Logan was trying to get Floyd out
of here it was fun it was great yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'd love to see
Logan Tyson bro come on
now come on that's a fight bro I was
here I
Logan wins that
whoa yeah I love Mike Mike come on man
at some point come on Father Time gotta
kick in bro come on
stop it it's my 5 56 Bradley no Mike
gotta be in his 60s how old is Mike
Tyson did you see Mike with uh Roy Jones
that's Roy Jones another senior citizen
yeah but Mike was doing his thing
how many you think they sold if you had
to guess hi Paul yeah um it's not going
to be crazy because it was at the time
it was on oh really I think you still
had to be a fight fan to know Sunday
Jake Paul was fighting at two o'clock
yeah yeah what are you thinking 400 000.
I don't know if it's that much I could
be wrong I don't I don't know I mean
I give it a couple hundred yeah I'll
pull up like what uh well he does this
if you want to bet on this fight or any
fights you do that [__] a bet on me to
use the promo go flagrant okay and
they're gonna match 50 of that initial
deposit bonus bonus okay up to a
thousand dollars so benonline.ag promo
code flagrant make sure you get that
[__] yeah yes Jake and Silva was 200 to
300 uh yeah I think that this might go
over because I think Tommy's pretty
popular in England yeah I love Island
just to fight family being connected so
yeah I think yeah great promo from a
fight family yeah I don't know how much
promo Silva did yeah just the fact that
this was going on for two years getting
picked and canceled and whatever it was
really interesting though the uh Tommy
Fury Tommy Fury talking about like what
he went through
and like you know he had pulled out of
the fight twice so he's like I'm walking
out of my home and everybody is just
calling me a [__] I'm afraid of
fighting Jake Paul like it was just this
like emotional release finally beating
the guy and I do understand that like
you build your whole identity as like
this fighter and you're part of a fight
family and the fight family is known for
being brave taking on all children last
name is Fury literally
your brother's first name is
and there was [__] out of his control
like
there was [__] out of his [__]
control basically him not being able to
come to the states like
there was some mob [__] basically why he
couldn't come to the states no not
saying he's connected but America wanted
to know if he was yeah yeah and
sometimes in those type of situations
it's better to not talk so I think Jake
Paul wins that fight two years ago
I would push back because I think Jake
Paul's improved as a boxer and Tommy I
don't move to the boxer yeah but I think
Jake put this amount of time Tommy's in
bakas is a child Jake every year that he
gets to fight yeah is adding like a huge
level of experience because he started
so late he's got to fight real boxes
though even if you're just sparring real
box he does he spars like really good
guys he does yeah like legit [__] he
can't look like it against Tommy free
he's like he didn't he's never been in
the ring with somebody moving around
like that that's what I looked at I hear
what you're saying what do you think of
this mentally I noticed when he was
gonna fight Tommy the first time Tommy
was a favorite then Tommy pulled out and
everybody's like yo I think Jake might
be the favorite I think Tommy might be
scared this is the first time he's
fighting really as a favorite in my
estimation do you think that [__] with
him mentally to not be the underdog and
not have the chip on your shoulder
interesting yeah baby
yeah I think it helps like
psychologically if you feel like you got
something to prove it because I felt
worried for him just off of that going
in it felt different this time I'd never
seen him as and it's a real boxer but
then you're the favorite against a
werewol
Jake Paul
that's it Boston is a sweet science baby
and if you know how to do that [__] a
little bit you will beat somebody who
doesn't know how to do it at all did you
see pornoy's thing what he said he's
like if if uh Tommy Sherry beats Jake
Paul I'll never speak on Combat Sports
ever again in my life I've never been so
sure of something ever
before the fight and then he apologized
afterwards he's like guys I'm an idiot
my bad
company before he had that but no he
probably saying that because him and
Logan is it Logan Barstool yeah yeah
come on man wearing a Barstool Hatter
yeah but he puts such a big so much
faith in it he's like I've never been so
sure of something I was like wow yeah it
made me think but do a real [__] suck
some dick
everybody like [__] money money he can
lose amount of money if you really
believe you put your lips down words
no he was right no I was right I didn't
have to honor it but uh but I bet sucks
some dick yo
like everybody always want to bet [__]
they can afford to lose afford to lose
the money you can't afford to lose a
[__] dick that's what I'm just saying
if you're so confident let me see how
confident you are